you know you know let me let me uh
phrase it like that uh Finance
professionals have seen
um their colleagues in sales and
marketing and r d being celebrated more
paid more and have better tools
so
um we want to give them they deserve a
consumer grade tool that will end their
frustration automate where needed clear
time for them to do more quality job
these are talented people it's a lot of
time do very tedious work so we want to
automate the stuff that doesn't require
thinking and clear their day and make
time for them to to do better quality
job
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of fam Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Roy Ben Daniel the
co-founder and CEO of received I started
building a revenue management platform
for finance teams before that he built
Visa's Partnerships team in Tel Aviv and
was part of the Visa Ventures Global
team he holds an LLB in law in
accounting from Tel Aviv University and
an MBA from Chicago Booth
Roy bandaniel welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for being here how are
you now great uh it's good to finally be
here thanks for having me thank you so
much for being here I am excited to stop
everything for 20 minutes and to dive
deep into your story and a really
interesting Journey as we've just read
to to the listeners uh running from a
platoon Commander to the legal sector
with an MBA in Chicago Booth to digital
Partnerships and Visa Ventures at visa
and uh for the last year a founder and
CEO of received and so a lot to unpack
and a lot to discuss
you know who are you Roy there's a lot
of different sites here at least five
that I can already see
uh well I'll tell my story
um I hope uh listeners will uh find it
interesting I grew up in uh Jerusalem uh
to a religious family
uh I'm not in religious today but
actually many of my values in my daily
life uh are based on the the values I
was educated in that education system my
mother was a teacher
my father
was a hard-working entrepreneur he was
uh he started the building his own
future and businesses when he was 13 and
when I grew up I saw him
um doing a very hard labor and saying
that the businesses
um and uh
providing for us basically and I learned
I learned a ton from from my parents and
a lot of who I am today is is thanks to
them
um
I served the
for four years in the military where I
was a tank platoon Commander
um and that taught me a ton I mean a lot
of my personalities today also uh is
thanks to that experience I learned the
meaning of camaraderie uh teamwork uh
leadership an interesting point is the
leadership without ranks because uh just
as a side note when you're an officer or
commander in reserve no one cares about
uh your uh your rank it's just it's just
your naked personality and and who you
are and how how you're able to drive
people just based on your
um what you do and what you say
um
how does that actually how did that come
about you know in your personal
experience because it sounds like
sort of you're reflecting back on on a
change between between being an active
on an active duty you know with ranks
versus being in the reserves and and how
that speaks to your ability to drive
people and to lead people and what what
that takes to exert that leadership
right
yeah I would say there's there's two
parts to that
um
so so the more the closer to me right
now
um is me being a CEO
um it's really easy to
um get confused and between the person
and uh and and the position that uh we
we feel everything is just a job
everything is temporary right we
shouldn't fall in love with anything
that that we do
um
and you know I want to be a type of CEO
that
um talks on an eye level and drives
people
by conviction by data by action by
setting an example it's really easy to
get confused sometimes and think oh I'm
the CEO they should just follow whatever
I do and that's just bad leadership in
my eyes
the second part of it is there's there's
uh I think for everyone anyone and
everyone that does anything
um leading without uh without the
hierarchy uh or without Authority story
rather
um is really really important I mean uh
first thing that comes to mind in my
experience is working at Visa I was a
focal point between
uh companies I onboarded to Visa these
CEOs of and founders of fintex and
um a lot of times when we I had an idea
for a partnership or a business deal I
would go to uh I was
I was
um
I was a satellite office in Tel Aviv and
I approached VPS and svps and and really
high rack people at Visa in the
headquarters in San Francisco
and I needed to convince them why this
made sense and why they should clear
uh it should give up their resources and
time and attention for what I'm
proposing and I think
any of us has has these two type of uh
leadership that they kind of need to
balance uh uh with
um between
um
and I think it when you rely on your
personality and your actions and
and your conviction rather than uh
what's my hierarchy in the organization
where I see the organization this person
should follow what I do
um it's just a better type of leadership
that brings better results
if that makes sense and most definitely
and so what was your really day today
like in Visa what were your
responsibilities what were you doing
um so at Visa
um I entered this uh 2015 and these were
early days of uh of the fintech uh I
call it the fintic Golden Era anywhere
between uh let's say 2015 and 2000 20
22. now we're entering this uh phase two
like in uh like uh like in Marvel now
it's not gonna look like uh what was
before but in any case these were early
days
um and Visa was this organization
that is a big financial institution
um
were compliance and Regulation and risk
aversion uh play a big part and for Good
Reasons by the way
um and they speak the fintechs were
coming up with the new value
propositions and getting some market
share
um and then Visa thoughts let's bring in
some people that will replicate our work
with banks to the fintech world so
basically my job entailed uh bringing
business
through the door meaning striking uh
commercial agreements with fintechs my
kpis were revenue and profit as much as
a account executive working with a bank
interesting but a bit more fun when you
get to work with the fast growth fintex
and did that Lee that did that
experience open sort of Your World to
what you're doing with received today
because it sounds in a similar you know
I can see sort of how that would evolve
from some core experiences and
understandings that you may have had
yeah
um Israel is a is a big uh B2B payments
uh Hub and it's been uh it's been so for
about a decade
um
so during my work at Visa working with
uh with B2B fintechs and my counterparts
in San Francisco New York at the at the
Visa headquarters I got a really good
understanding of the B2B payments space
um I work with our customers and and our
customers customers and understood uh
what needs are being met and what are
the kind of the white spaces in the
market
um I also developed this philosophy that
um a huge value unlocking B2B payments
is in the process as I call it so let me
explain
um please so so people in in the
payments industry or fintech industry
always talk about the the huge 20
trillion dollar uh B2B payments uh
opportunity it can be 20 trillion a
gazillion trillion doesn't matter right
it's it's a huge opportunity uh I always
note it is bigger than b2c
and I think one mistake people do is
that they look uh under the the Lamppost
meaning uh b2c Innovation with a b2c
payment Innovation is in the payment
mechanic and it's really not the same in
B2B payments what does that mean what
does that mean payment mechanic
so in b2c you have a high volume and
high velocity of uh of uh of transaction
imagine that e-commerce website young
Mills of transactions SmartThings
actions yeah yeah they need to optimize
for chargebacks and right and for
routing stuff like that B2B payments uh
don't look the same you're looking at a
lot of the time when it's B2B sales
you're looking at Big transactions that
are not as complicated to to do the
complication is in the process in apar
accounts payable accounts receivable the
collaboration the theme process
how a payment request goes out how is
it's collected how it's reconciled
um and that's what I mean by the process
got it okay that that makes sense and so
what what is sort of the the world that
you're in with with received
um
so when we when we started talking with
um my co-founder and uh Mysterio Shai
and I we started talking with the
finance teams and uh and CFOs
um we understood that uh uh for uh fast
growing and and dynamic B2B businesses
the accounts receivables and an
invoicing process is is really broken
and what I mean by that is that
um
the CFO office has
um these Antiquated old systems
um with kind of this
one-size-fits-all notion that just
doesn't cut it so for example for
technology companies uh they're in order
to have invoices go out accurately And
Timely you need a process or or a
machine that knows how to automate for
a pricing model logic and contracts and
usage management usage is when you pay
as as you go like uh I'll charge you uh
per API call right
an old systems just don't cut it and and
that leaves the finance teams Scrabble
for
[Music]
um uh for uh to manage all all these
things on spreadsheets we call some of
the problem the revenue spaghetti when
your Revenue model is really complicated
you need something to manage that as a
system right so all systems kind of push
them outside to manage things on a
manual
Manner and that creates you know the
regular spill of
um a lot of time waste a lot of
frustration a lot of Errors yeah bad
collection a bad cash cycle
um and we're building a revenue
management that will really solve the uh
reimagine how accounts receivable and
invoicing looks like for B2B companies
from contract to reconciliation
that it's it's really awesome uh where
if you had to you know think really
about you know the mark the way the
market you know transformed over the
last I guess decade or so how did the
market transformation of the B2B
you know uh payments payment or revenue
streams how did they evolve or change
leading up to
and you know received AI being you know
something that's really relevant in 2023
yeah uh we actually call ourselves
received not received Ai and we're
probably well I want you to plug in the
website so that people know now to go to
the series yes I'm doing my service here
man sir sir
um uh okay so
the way we think about it in in very uh
basic terms is there was in apar which
are the processes augmenting the the
payment there's been
um this uh generation 1.0
where uh things moved from offline to
online right and I think you'll see that
in in many other segments
um
and that has been transformed and
maturing kind of in the last decade okay
so if things are working if you have
um pretty basic needs
um and then
um generation 2.0 is where things become
smarter more collaborative more
sophisticated more API driven more
flexible I think a great case study for
that is Corporate spend or spend
management right so think about what
ramp mesh brexit
they said we have this generation 1.0
yeah which is expense management and
card issuance like in a sense they did
nothing new right but they said let's
couple these things together and now uh
CFO can give marketing manager uh uh a
very specific budget for a specific week
for a conference they're going to over a
card and that's never been done before
so 2.0 is making things smarter in
essence
okay and the big mile the big step
function this is going to cause
for you know the way that the big ship
this is that received is going to now
bring to the table for these b2bs as a
result of these shifts what is sort of
the vision that you're that you're
sending out here
so let me do it by uh we'll do a
two-parter one for the company and one
for the finance team
um for the company it's about uh cash
flow and revenue Health
um just being
um being able to collect cash faster and
being on being on top of uh your Revenue
much much better because we're going to
build the revenue recognition engine
over our
um over our uh system uh next year
um it brings visibility in real time to
sea level Executives being able to
um uh
um uh this have better decision making
um and actually being more agile I I
about think about uh five to ten CEOs
told me of fast growth companies my
actual bottleneck of my business model
like I want to open a new Channel I want
to charge in a different way my
bottleneck is my invoicing system how
ridiculous is that right so it's also
also about business agility uh for
finest teams for finance professionals
which are really Our Heroes
um it's about
um
you know you know let me let me uh
phrase it like that virus professionals
have seen
um their colleagues in sales and
marketing and r d being celebrated more
paid more and have better tools
so
um we want to give them they deserve a
consumer grade tool that will end their
frustration automate where needed clear
time for them to do more quality job
these are talented people it's a lot of
time do very tedious work so we want to
automate the stuff that doesn't require
thinking and clear their day and make
time for them to to do better quality
job to think
it's um that's pretty awesome and your
own
experience transitioning to the
entrepreneurial side and to you know
being now founder and CEO after working
you know at visa and being a commander
in the Army and Chicago Booth this is
quite a quite a shift I'm sure
yeah for me a Founder is
um
it's a special Journey
I would say there's there's two big
things that are on my mind when I think
why do this because it's a it's a
treacherous road for sure uh which
requires a lot of sacrifices and a lot
of hard work
um first of all it's about solving
people's problems so at Visa I didn't
really have a say about what what
problems I can solve
um and now you know shy and I
um start with a blank sheet and now we
have this idea that we raise capital for
and and people and and and we build the
product and we're starting to solve we
have early customers
um so we're starting to solve uh
people's problem and it's it's amazing
to see someone so happy using our
product and the second part is creative
freedom which kind of can connects to
uh to the first point
um as founder you get a complete say
um in how the the stuff that you create
is going to look like sales marketing
product
uh company culture whatever I mean it's
it's it's you uh the bug stops uh with
you so
um I I find that energizing in the power
really
amazing boy thank you so much for your
time uh best of luck on the journey with
received and I'm going to be turning
from the side and uh really uh really
appreciate your energy and your time
best of luck thanks Mikhail it's uh it's
a pleasure to be here and thanks for the
opportunity
foreign